I got attacked on the internet when I
said Messi's better than Ronaldo oh yeah
that's controversial and so that's a
very intense maximalist Community there
uh the other one that surprised me is
when I said
now I did it ingest okay folks I said
emacs is a better ID than Vim I love
emacs I agree
listen I have trauma I wake up sweating
sometimes at night thinking Max Master
is the the Vim the Vim people are after
me they're everywhere they're in the
shadows no Vim is an amazing and it's
actually surprised I've recently learned
that it's
um still even more so than before an
incredibly active community so a lot of
people wrote but do you use space Max
it's just emacs and Vim
no I haven't I use raw
um but but so you got to use yeah hold
on a second I actually recently I have
recently said you know what
um Let's Make Love Not War and I went to
vs code
I uh I went to a more modern idea but uh
because I did most of my program emacs I
did most of anything as one does an
emacs just because I also love lisp so I
can customize everything then I realized
like
like how long will vim and emacs be
around really well I was thinking as a
programmer
looking like 10 20 years out
you know I should challenge myself to
learn new ideas to learn uh the the new
tools that the majority of the community
is using so that I can understand what
are the benefits of the cost I found
myself getting a little too comfortable
with the tools that I've grew up with
sure I think one of the fundamental ways
of being as a programmer is anyone
involved with technology
based on how quickly it's evolving is to
keep learning new tools like the way of
life should be constantly learning
you're not a mathematician or a
physicist or any of those disciplines
that are more stable this is like
everything's changing cryptos like you
said a perfect example that you have to
constantly update your understanding of
the of of digital Finance constantly in
order to be able to function in order to
be able to criticize it uh in order to
be able to know what to invest in so
yeah that that was why I did uh I tried
pie charm a bunch uh the whole jet
Brands uh uh infrastructure and then
also vs code because that's really
popular I mean you know Adam and um uh
Sublime of those I've been I've been
exploring I've been exploring UCS code
is amazing you should check out space
Max I'm just going to give one more
pitch for it it's just basically like a
customizable customizable configuration
well emacs is already customizable but
it's uh
it's pretty useful I'm not even much of
a coder but for like certain journaling
applications or like time management
like I find it really useful so
but anyway wait we're so like in I feel
like half this podcast is what it should
have been in the half of it's just us
nerding out about our own engineering
like idiosyncrasies sorry sorry guys